[Music]
does friction exist only between solid
parts not necessarily friction is
offered by fluids like air and water as
well and this force of friction due to
fluids is referred to as a fluid
friction the friction we've seen between
solid parts is referred to as dry
friction the major states of matter are
solid liquid and gas and liquids and
gases are generally referred to as
fluids while liquids and gases
considered to be fluids one common
characteristic of fluids is that they
have no fixed shape and can be easily
deformed let's discuss a bit more about
fluid friction in this lesson just like
solids fluids to exert a force of
friction when objects move through them
do you think a offers resistance doesn't
seem intuitive right when I drop a stone
from a particular height it falls to the
ground does air offer resistance here of
course it does what about water does it
offer resistance yes when the fish swim
they encounter fluid resistance from the
water the frictional force exerted by
fluids is also referred to as drag what
does fluid friction depend on let's talk
about the first obvious factor it's the
nature of the fluid to understand this
point you just need to answer a simple
question an object moves from point A to
B through air and in the second case a
similar object travels from A to B
through water which object do you think
encounters more resistance clearly it
will be the water right yes more the
thickness of the fluid greater will be
the frictional force acting on an object
which moves through it there's a term
which describes a fluids resistance to
flow
it's called viscosity so here we can say
that the water is more viscous than air
higher the viscosity more will be the
since offered by that fluid honey is
more viscous than water which is why it
offers more friction than water that was
the first factor affecting fluid
friction the nature of the fluid can you
think of any other factor another factor
is the speed with which the object is
traveling higher the speed of the object
moving through a fluid greater will be
the frictional force acting on it a
vehicle traveling at hundred miles per
hour will face more drag of air as
compared to a similar vehicle traveling
at 50 miles per hour apart from the
nature of the fluid and the speed with
which the object is traveling is there
any other factor on which fluid friction
depends on yes it also depends on the
shape of the object and it's really
important that we understand this factor
well have you ever thought about why
aeroplanes are shaped like this it could
just have been a rectangular box flying
in the air how have the fish evolved to
be shaped like this why are the ships
designed to be given the shape there's a
reason for all this they're given a
streamline shape to minimize the fluid
friction the shape of the aeroplane if
you notice is like that of a bird this
process of giving an object a particular
shape to decrease the fluid friction is
known as streamlining streamlining the
object can greatly reduce the resistance
offered by the fluid a car faces less of
friction from air as it has a
streamlined shape a bus on the other
hand will face more air friction as it
doesn't have a streamlined shape so
these were the different factors on
which fluid friction depends nature of
the fluid the speed of the object
flowing through the fluid and the shape
of the object
[Music]